later this year so let's share some more
details about the platform and what
you'll need to get started at launch
you'll get the best experience playing
with our new stadia troller it's
designed specifically for streaming
games and it includes a capture button
for your game footage and a button to
access the Google assistant of course
you can also play stadia games with any
supported game controller or with a
mouse and keyboard the only other thing
you need is a screen to play on want to
play on the HD TV in your living room
just plug in a chromecast ultra if you'd
rather play on your laptop desktop or
tablet open a Chrome browser window our
vision is for stadia to run on any
screen that runs Chrome or you can use
the stadia app on your pixel three will
be expanding to more screens down the
line to including more smartphones when
you're ready to play the stadia
controller connects directly to your
game running in the Google Data Center
that direct connection is key to
providing the highest possible
performance and the best streaming
experience we have so many more details
on the stadia controller which you can
find at Stadio calm we're also a tweet
away at Google stadia to answer all your
questions we're very excited to
introduce you to a number of new titles
coming to stadia at launch
let's take a look I'm a wolf raised
video
trying to follow